un enfrentamiento mortal que sumerge a
todo el país en un callejón sin salida
por un lado el general abdel fata
alburham número uno del ejército y de
Sudán desde su golpe de estado en 2021
por el otro Mohamed ham dane daglo jefe
del poderoso grupo paramilitar de las
fuerzas de apoyo rápido que ahora tiene
sus ojos puestos en el poder todo
comenzó en diciembre de 2018 las
imágenes no tienen precedentes miles de
personas salen a las calles de las
principales ciudades protestan contra el
precio del pan que subió tres veces
rápidamente Omar el becchir quien
durante tres décadas había gobernado
Sudán con puño de hierro concentra la
ira popular cuatro meses después en
abril de 2019 El dictador es derrocado
por el ejército los militares ahora
tienen la sartén por el mango en julio
del mismo año desmantelan violentamente
un campamento de protesta en jartum el
resultado 130 muertos durante el verano
invitan a los civiles a la mesa de
negociaciones resultado se firma un
acuerdo que prevé la vuelta de los
civiles al poder a finales de 2022 Pero
esto no sucederá en octubre de 2021 otro
golpe militar las autoridades de
transición se disuelven y los civiles
son expulsados Empezando por el Primer
Ministro handalla
el general alburjane se impuso a la
población un año y medio después es un
fracaso no logró estabilizar Sudán un
país ahora plagado de luchas muy
violentas